في الواقع سهام الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه
على الاراضي اللبنانيه لم تتوقف خلال
الساعات القليله الماضيه هذا على المستوى
الميداني اخر هذه التطورات الغارات التي
شنتها المقاتلات الحربيه الاسرائيليه على
بلده كفركلا وبحسب المعلومات استهدفت
منازل ومنشات داخل تلك البلده ما ادى الى
اضرار في هذه المناطق المستهدفه بالاضافه
الى قصف مدفعي ايضا يطال عدد من البلدات
في الق طعين الاوسط والغربي وبالتالي
التصعيد الميداني الاسرائيلي باتجاه
الداخل اللبناني مستمر طبعا هناك ترقب
كبير لكيفيه تعامل حزب الله ومقاربات حزب
الله لمساله اغتيال القائد الميداني
البارز في وحده الرضوان وسام طويل يوم امس
في بلده خربه سلم اليوم الحزب يشيع وسام
طويل في بلدته خربه سلم وقد تكون هناك
مواقف سياسيه خلال مراسم التشييع توضح هذه
المقاربه وتتحدث عن كيفيه تعامل الحزب في
المرحله المقبله مع كافه التطورات هنا في
هذه المنطقه الحدوديه طبعا اختيال طويل
يعتبر محطه مهمه في مسار هذه المواجهه
المفتوحه بين حزب الله والجانب الاسرائيلي
ربطا بما يجري في قطاع غزه هو القائد
الميداني الابرز والاعلى رتبه الذي تغتاله
اسرائيل منذ اكتوبر الماضي وبالتالي طبعا
هناك متابعه للرد الذي يمكن ان يقوم به
حزب الله حيال هذه العمليه طبعا كلكل هذه
التطورات تؤشر الى تصعيد اسرائيلي متصاعد
باتجاه حزب الله وبالتالي باتجاه لبنان
رصدنا في الفتره الماضيه طبعا تصاعدا في
وتيره الغارات الاسرائيليه على الاراضي
اللبنانيه بالاضافه الى عمليه اغتيال نائب
رئيس المكتب السياسي في حركه حماس الاسبوع
الماضي في قلب الضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت
وتاتي يوم امس عمليه اغتيال وسام طويل
لتزيد هذه الوتيره من التصعيد الاسرائيلي
وكان مسؤولون لبنانيون حذروا في الايام
القليله الماضيه من المحاولات الاسرائيليه
لجر لبنان الى مواجهه اوسع والى مزيد من
التصعيد ربطا بما يجري في قطاع غزه
وبالتالي هناك حال من الترقب طبعا وحال من
التوتر تسود المناطق الحدوديه كما ذكرتم
حزب الله يوم امس اعلن عن تنفيذه خمس
عمليات عسكريه باتجاه المواقع العسكريه
الاسرائيليه ما يزال الحزب يسعى الى الحاق
اكبر ضرر ممكن بالقوات الاسرائيليه
المنتشره قباله الحدود اللبنانيه الموقف
الواضح لحزب الله مازال على حاله جبهه
جنوب لبنان هي جبهه مسانده وتضامن مع قطاع
غزه وهدفها الاساسي الدفع باتجاه وقف
لاطلاق النار في قطاع غزه وتخفيف الضغط عن
قطاع غزه ولكن طبعا كل التطورات التي حصلت
في الايام القليله الماضيه تشير الى تصعيد
قادم الى تصاعد في وتيره التوتر هنا في
هذه المناطق الحدوديه وخشيه من ان تنفجر
الامور في المرحله المقبله ربطا بهذا
التصعيد الاسرائيلي
وربطاً وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه لبنان
وطبعا الملف الاساسي على طاوله البحث هو
الاوضاع هنا في جنوب لبنان وكيفيه مقاربه
هذه الاوضاع ومحاوله تهدئه الاوضاع علما
ان كل المعلومات كانت اشارت في المرحله
الماضيه الى ان الوفود التي التقت حزب
الله وتحديدا مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بورال سمع من
الحزب كلاما واضحا بان اي حديث واي تفاوض
بشان تطورات الاوضاع هنا في الجنوب
اللبناني لا يمكن ان يتم قبل وقف اطلاق
النار في قطاع غزه وبالتالي في هذا المجال
وضمن هذه التطورات الميدانيه وهذه
المعطيات السياسيه يرتسم المشهد هنا
وسنبقى معك في المتابعه طبعا جوني تانيوس
مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من مرجعيون جنوب
لبنان شكرا جزي